Now remember,
we started off by saying we want
2D transformations where we
basically have a matrix M
to give us values of any point
p to give a point p prime.
Let's look at what we would do to
get something simple as translation.
So what we want to do for
translation is of course,
we would have the axis for x and y.
And we want to translate it into
a different location again from this and
x and y, so this has been translated.
Let's say for a lack of better
words by an amount, tx and ty.
Okay?
How we represent this in this new
homogenous coordinate system?
Well, again, this is what we interested
in x, y prime, x prime, y prime, 1.
X, y and of course,
now let's think about what M would be.
By just looking at this, you notice
that we can actually construct it.
Diagonal terms are all 1's, and these,
these two axis could just be tx and ty.
And if you actually do the math,
you'll basically notice
that what we will come up with
would be is x prime is going
to be equal to x plus tx and
y prime would be equal to y plus ty.
That gives us what we wanted.
So translation is easily
modelled this way.
What about scale?
Again, here, the goal is to go from
this image, to a larger image.
In this case, again,
what we did before, the same two by two
we had looked at before, with sx and sy,
can go into these two values here, and,
of course, the rest of it will work out,
because what will happen is x prime
times sx, x would be the result.
And that's exactly we want.
So this gives me a nice
three by three matrix for
being able to doing things like scaling.
What about rotation?
In rotation, basically I want to take an
image and being able to kind of rotate
it around where basically how I
need to know things like theta.
And here the theta would
be this value here.
All right.
And we know how to do this.
Again, we know when if, somebody
gave me a theta, I can compute using
this cosine theta minus sine theta,
just in this two by two.
And again, these are 0, 0, 1.
What gives me x prime, y prime.
And we know how to do this too.
The good thing with homogenous
coordinate system is,
these two parameters help us do
things like model translations.
We can also do shear the same way.
Start with an image.
We want to shear it.
Remember, this was when
shear happened like this.
And of course again, we would put
the shears in the off diagonal terms.
All the diagonals would be run.
You can play around with this yourself
in these matrix multiplies and
you'll see it works.